hey everyone my name is syndra I'm from
Oslo Norway I'm going to do talk today
on moving beyond virtual DOM and state
management yeah this is my first talk
ever at a conference so I'm a little
nervous but let's hope it's gonna work
out fine I'm co-founder of something
that's called scream be calm which is an
interactive screen casting platform and
I'm also the creator for language that's
called inba which I'm going to show you
some parts of today so first I'm not
sure if any of you have heard about
scream bar but I'm just gonna show you
for like two minutes what it is because
it's actually pretty cool it's a new
sort of screencasting technology so we
have open courses everything is free
here is a react course I can go to into
a video and you can basically just scrub
around and and see the presentation
exactly as you would with a regular
video but you can also jump in and pause
the screencasts and jump into the code
and change stuff see how that effects
the examples that the presenter is
actually cheating you move around look
through the different files etc and then
when you think you understands stuff
then you can just continue watching the
the thing and you can record your own
screencasts in this technology as well
this whole platform front end and back
end is written in the language that I'm
going to present it just another plug
we're also having a stand out there by
the name of get speak which is the the
business version of scream buff internal
tool for four teams so be sure to just
come on over and chat later if that
sounds interesting so the beginning or
it's not beginning because J Kurian and
the imperative way of doing stuff was
was really the beginning of real web
applications but over the last five
years or more
almost every web developer has started
creating applications in a declarative
manner like with declarative rendering
and what that means is that these
frameworks now
allows you to basically describe how you
want the whole application to look or
how you want the page to look based on
some state of your application so you're
not responding to to events and mutating
the the view directly you are rather
just declaring this is how I want it
look depending on any state and then the
framework will take care of the magic
for you because the obvious problem with
this is that you can't just re render
and re-create the whole dom on every on
every update you can't basically replace
the whole page every time something
happens so people have tried to come up
with some clever solutions to work
around this and the by far the most well
known solution which was introduced by
react is called a virtual Dom so instead
of rear-ending the the page itself every
time it will basically request a new
virtual representation of your page and
then we will then we'll take that
virtual representation match it up to
the previous virtual representation and
find out what parts it needs to change
in the real Dom because their assumption
was that the real Dom is way too slow
and that this is the best way to to
actually apply the changes and the
process of making the view sync up with
your data is called Dom reconciliation
so that is the concept of trying to find
out what has really changed and applying
that and the main question that I'm
going to ask throughout this
presentation is what if Dom
reconciliation was infinitely fast like
how would that change the way we create
applications today but it allow us to
start working in almost kind of a new
paradigm that might be so what if Dom
reconciliation is really slow because
that's the stay today it actually is
really slow originally react was sold as
a really performant thing and it was
sold as like the virtual DOM was a
tastic solution to this it's just
blazing fast so you never need to care
about how you render stuff and that
turns out not to be true I don't have a
presenter screener so I don't really
know the next slide but I'm hoping so
the thing is that to make sure we can do
this declarative rendering even while
the dome reconciler is slow we need to
follow some strict rules and you might
not think of them as rules today but
they really are and we don't want to
sell you these ideas and tell you that
you need to do this to help the poor
virtual Dom which is way too slow we
want to sell it to you as a grand idea
we want to sell to you that this is the
best way to make applications this is
the only way to make them bug free and
so we need to make sure that you believe
that it's actually good for you to do
these things to use these patterns and
I'm not saying it's not good but I'm
saying you should have a choice when you
develop an application of what way you
want to manage your state so the first
lawyer the first thing we really need to
get all of you to believe is that
bi-directional data flows are just bad
for everything we need you to believe
that everything must come from the
parent and down in a strict hierarchy
and the real reason for this for doing
this in my opinion is to help the poor
virtual Dom that doesn't really know
about changes if they happened for deep
into the hierarchies so if if the
virtual Dom is not able to see that oh
no props has changed here so nothing
will have changed deep deep down in this
this tree then it basically doesn't work
because doing all those checks for
itself is too slow and the next thing we
need to sell which is I could do a whole
talk on that with it would be a huge
rant but still is the concept of
immutability and we've all learned that
immutability is basically the only way
to make sure our application isn't
exploding and crapping out all sorts of
stuff because mutability is just the
root of all evil basically and before we
act before the virtual Dom I don't think
more than like 5% in the JavaScript
community even knew what immutability
was and the truth is that immutability
is a relatively ineffective and very
very complex way of helping the virtual
Dom know when something has changed so
is someone here in this room raise their
hand and there's a painter here who
wants to just keep everything up to date
and repaint the room everything
something happens then if he was the
virtual Dom he wouldn't notice if anyone
raised their hand because it's still the
same person so the genius behind
immutability is that you would take that
person throw them out of the room clone
him raise the hand of the clone and put
him back in the room but that would help
either because the virtual DOM is
sitting in the corner and just like it's
the same room so it's probably nothing
has changed so then you would just need
to reconstruct the room take all the
people clone them into this room you you
get to keep the same people that's a
huge benefit but you replace the one
person who raised his hand and voila the
paint will now see um something is
changing this room I think I'll try to
re-render but this process is very slow
but if you subscribe to it then it's
okay but you need to follow some strict
rules I'm going to show you a world
where you don't need to follow these
rules and right now it's pretty chaotic
you need to make sure you don't shoot
yourself in the foot or other places I
think it's pretty accurate actually the
amount of people who's standing there is
about the size of this community today
so there are some issues but we are
solving the the Dom were considered
reconciliation in a totally different
way than the Dinan virtual DOM and the
performance
to say the least better a lot better so
first I'm just gonna drag you through
this language like very very quickly
it was started we've been working on it
for eight years now I think I've been
using it internally for a lot of
projects I'm not good at writing
documentation I really hate it so I
start a bunch of different projects
instead so it's been open source for a
few years but hasn't really taken off
and there are many reasons for that it's
a new language language it will look
strange to most of you especially if you
don't come from Ruby or Python which is
heavily inspired by but it's supports
all these basic things that you will
have in a language and it also has the
concept of Dom tags as a native data
type or a primitive like a first-class
citizen in the language so that's kind
of like JSX but it works at a much
deeper level so you can instantiate tags
we have again it's very very tailored to
create web applications so the language
has a lot of short hands for doing the
things you will often do in these
applications like applying class names
applying conditional class names like
this so this p here will render with the
class name red if this condition is true
or true the-- and you can define custom
components like you can in react but
it's it's at a very deep level a part of
the language itself and that includes
the fact that you can let's say let's
see literature text index so you can
have conditional rendering like it's all
part of the language so inside of your
whole render trees you can have
conditions you can obviously render
lists like loop through things and and
render render laits
lists it's all annotation based as many
of you will not like that I love that
but when we compile these tags like this
component here looks kind of like a
react component
it is basically has a render method and
this randomized method says that within
this tag component we should have an h1
and a P with these class names and these
texts and when we compile it it looks
something like this and this code is
relatively easy to understand it's not
how you would write JavaScript yourself
I guess but it is easy to understand
what's going on and the first part of
the performance already comes here and
it might not be apparent and that is
instead of gathering all the properties
and details about a tag in an object we
actually apply each part like each
property or class name or anything in a
chain of setters that mutate this object
and these tiny methods they know what
they are supposed to do the JavaScript
engines are really good at enlightening
these types of functions and optimizing
them and the other thing is when you
start doing dynamic stuff then we
actually split up the creation of Dom
elements and their properties and the
updates into two separate logical
branches and this is happening in the
compiler so when you write this view
it's basically just a an h1 title
welcome and a paragraph which has a
class name read half of the time it's
it's rendering this is what that
compiles to we set the children set the
class name set the text and we set a
class name read if something is true but
if you look closely here when we call
render the first time then this will
happen like we will create this and then
it will add the class name but the
second time all the static parts are
already cached so it will skip basically
skip this whole part here and only do a
single operation which is toggling the
class name read on the paragraph so this
concept is actually very simple it gets
way more messy when we start introducing
conditional tags
and dynamic lists and stuff but it's
still depending on the same core idea
and that core idea is very different
from the virtual Dom because we are
working directly with Dom elements so
instead of trying to like spend the rest
of this talk trying to show you in band
all the quirky syntax and trying to
convince you that you should start using
this now I'm not trying to convince you
that there's the documentation is shitty
and all of that but if you're curious it
is if it is a joy to work with in large
applications at least for us so when we
usually benchmark things in the web
world we test things like how fast is it
at creating 10,000 to-do items and
removing them in one single operation or
how fast is the framework to do a lot of
mutations and those benchmarks are okay
but they mostly test the performance of
the browser because there are so many
actual Dom operations and actual
notations happening that you're no
longer testing the core Dom reconciler
and my point that I'm trying to convince
you of later in this talk is that that
is by far the most important thing to
measure because in a regular application
in the real world the most common
scenario is that almost nothing is
changed maybe a single tiny thing will
change this its title or to-do item is
suddenly marked as done or not and being
if the Dom reconciler is fast enough if
it is infinitely fast then we could
potentially just rerender the whole
application from root every single time
we didn't even need to worry about
whether the data has changed or not we
just rerender every time and then we can
know we have a guarantee we know that
the view will always be in sync with
your state and you would not need any
sort of
servals you would need to listen to when
the data has changed you wouldn't need
to do the approach of mob X and similar
which are low love love by the way you
could basically just work with plain
data for your state and in this
benchmark here which is an
implementation of the to do MVC example
like the reference example for in before
react and for view where we have a
shared library that takes care of
mutating the state it's actually
mutating it's not creating these weird
immutable structures and we're forcing
each of the implementations to basically
do a full Dom reconciliation we give
them a new state and we say you're not
supposed to know whether anything has
changed or not just make sure my whole
view is up-to-date
after I force you to to do that
reconciliation and it's deterministic so
when I step through this you will see
that the end state after the same amount
of operations will be the same in each
example so this is just stepping through
but if we try to run this so in bytes
using this memorized dump technique
react is using the virtual Dom view is
also using essentially a virtual Dom
they have some promising new
improvements in in version 3 which I'm
looking forward to to try out but when
we try to run and run this benchmark now
we're basically just trying to get as
far as we can in these situations and
see how many full Dom reconcile a
reconciliation iterations we can do per
time unit so if we start with Impa we
see that we are now past like 500
thousand a million operations like two
hundred and eight thousand operations a
second react when did the eight thousand
seven hundred and view I guess a little
over lower at seven thousand seven
hundred so when I try to convince people
of these benchmarks the obvious first
objection is that I'm an idiot that I
don't understand what I'm testing that I
prob
confused and and messed up something
about asynchronous rendering or
synchronous rendering that I don't
understand that one of the benchmark
works
benchmarks one of the frameworks is
batching stuff and the others are not
you are free to think that but I've been
working on this for almost eight years
now it is not the case
I do actually know what we're testing
and again I would claim that this type
of benchmark is the most important thing
to test Dom reconciliation performance
and I would even say that there is one
kind of test that is even more important
and that would be how fast the Dom
reconciler can reconcile this if there
were no changes at all as I talked about
because if it's really fast then then we
can start rendering on every frame we
can start rendering whenever we think
something might have changed in the
application and just don't worry about
it so we can remove all the observables
and all that stuff so if we run that
kind of benchmark just doing a hundred
thousand iterations where we don't
change the state but we neither do we
let the reconciler know that nothing has
changed so it has to find out itself
we're not helping which should component
update or a crazy immutable framework or
using like some sort of weird data state
management system so this is the flame
chart for Impa doing these 100000
iterations it does it in less than 100
milliseconds and it spends around 5
milliseconds in garbage collection this
is the react version of the same thing
it takes eight point three seconds it's
over eighty times slower and it spends
more time doing garbage collection than
in bestowing the whole thing and I think
that is actually pretty important
because I'm not suggesting that the real
world performance difference of inba and
react in a regular application today is
huge that's not what I'm suggesting I'm
suggesting that
this real-world performance improvement
which is real lets you develop
applications in a different way which is
simpler this is the same thing for view
you can see in this flame charts the
complexity like you see a hint of the
complexity behind the diffing algorithms
and what's going on behind the scenes
you can see that view is even crazier
but view also has a lot of built-in key
value observable stuff so that's kind of
natural but as I said the the objection
after I've been arguing with people for
like a few hours about whether the
benchmark is really cheating or not the
new objection is obviously like react is
fast enough there's no reason to use
this and to that I would say that it's
fast enough until it isn't so even today
your application would not become 20
times faster for the user he wouldn't
feel that the button is clearing
clicking twenty times faster if you
rewrote in in embalm but I'm saying that
the app could truly be twenty times more
complex your views could be twenty times
more complex or larger before you start
running into the same performance
bottlenecks that you might run into with
say react today and the problem with
that is as long as your example is as
long as your application is fast enough
that you can basically reconcile without
it's degrading performance then it
doesn't matter what you use like every
framework will be good enough but when
you start running into these problems
when you start running into the problem
of the reconcile being too slow like
you're rendering a list and it's
actually lagging when you change a page
or doing whatever then you're in big
trouble because the only way you can
resolve this is you will start to need
to restructure application you might
either need to change your your state
management framework to something that
is more efficient more granular that
managed to track the the change is more
if
or you might need to start introducing
should component updates and just do a
lot of work that I think the Dom
reconciler should have been able to do
in the first place so again it doesn't
really improve user experience that much
this is a very fancy graph showing the
experience of users and improved
rendering performance there's a ton of
research behind this so my hypothesis is
that it doesn't really matter that much
to users but sometimes there will be
like a huge bump in user experience and
that will happen the times when
performin has improved enough to be able
to kind of change paradigms because then
the developers are able to create better
and larger applications and are able to
spend more of their time building great
user interfaces great applications and
less time on solving weird bugs and and
trying to make sure stuff is working
efficiently so my point here is that
with raw Dom modifications imperative
rendering that we did before things were
working ok but for the developer things
became massively easier at the moment we
could jump over to something like the
declarative rendering with the help of
the virtual DOM and for a long time so
people created virtual Dom's that are
getting relatively efficient like in
that constrained type of technique
people created virtual domes that are
much faster than react but react is
still fast enough for most of this stuff
it is only when you get far enough when
you actually get to that 10x 20x maybe
50x performance that's the moment when
you can actually start doing things in a
different way and I call that careless
declarative rendering and that's
basically just the same thing you're
doing
same thing that you didn't react but you
don't really care about how you manage
the state or you choose state management
framework that suits you not one that
suits the D virtual Dom so I actually
think that I talked way too fast
and the time basically at the end of the
talk but if you have any questions I
could rant on about immutability if
anyone wants that or I could take some
questions
so do anyone have any comment or yeah so
the library footprint size is 57
kilobytes around that I don't remember
exactly now because it's we're at 1.4 so
it's a little smaller than react and
most of the others the funny thing is
that this memorize the Dom concept is
actually much much simpler than a
virtual Dom on a conceptual level like
it wouldn't be too difficult for you to
understand it and so it requires less
code as well yeah I I gotta go No
yeah so I actually got a phone call now
No so one good thing about it is that in
BA compiles to accept the tags in in BA
the rest of it compiles to relatively
clean regular JavaScript and it's fully
interoperable so you can both export as
long as you compile the info files you
can you can publish an NPM package that
is going to be used in the regular
JavaScript system and inside of scream
Bob we obviously use a lot of regular
NPM packages from from JavaScript so it
is just it's kind of like CoffeeScript
in that sense so you just use the same
it was yeah
yeah actually I didn't know about it
until a few days ago yeah I think so as
I said and I also think that in you the
next generation rendering in angular is
also doing some kind of the same yeah
hey yeah and and to be honest like I've
been working on in buff for a long time
and been using it for a long time time
and I'm not naive like I'm not expecting
everyone to pick up this new weird
language with all these things so I
would be extremely happy if some of the
bigger frameworks took these ideas from
the memorize DOM and use them themselves
because it would be very cool if more
than ten developers could could get the
benefit from a very very new
like a basically a revolutionary new way
of doing this and maybe it's just time
now that there will be others that start
coming out with using the same concepts
to be honest I wasn't really I was just
shocked about the performance myself
because I didn't really intend it to be
that fast in the beginning it was more
like this is the way it makes sense to
do it in Nimba and for the first few
hours after I wrote the first like you I
benched implementation I spent the time
trying to understand why I was cheating
and how I was cheating in all of that
yeah yeah so the main the main reason is
because it's an old language not a new
language like today I might not have
started writing it but whenever I get go
back to react I'm very glad that I did
but at the time when I started the
ecosystem in Java sleep was just totally
different like it was basically was crap
and I came from the Ruby world and I
loved the simplicity there the elegance
and I wanted to write replicate that in
the browser so yeah that's reason yeah
yes that's the thing in bar is fully
agnostic when it comes to state
management so you could definitely use
if you've for some extremely weird
reason wanted to use Redux again then
you could use that in in bar
definitely and you could you can
absolutely use mob X if you want to do
that throw on the data side you often do
need some sort of framework to to cache
expensive commutations in the in the
business layer so it makes sense to use
with some other things but it also has
similar things like food component
updates too much react we've never used
it in swim bar and it's actually kind of
fun I'd like the thing you see here in
swim ba this is rear-ending the root of
the whole whole application on every
frame or whenever anything is changing
like the the time the where the timeline
is the listserve of files everything
like that and it's it's actually working
pretty well ya know so I've been
thinking a little bit bit about that I
thought that at least and frame a
framework like if you should be able to
compile their views in a similar manner
but I saw on Twitter that that Avenue
said that it wouldn't work because they
support this render function thing I
know for a fact that a framework like
react wouldn't be able to just because
it uses a very different way of thinking
about these these concepts like in the
virtual Dom when you call render you're
basically not mutating anything you're
just returning a description of how you
want something to look but I do think it
would be possible or it might be
possible to create and JSX compiler or
basically a JSX plugin that could
compile the JSX tags to something
similar and that you could create create
a JavaScript framework on top of that
cause I could base
they recreate the the tag system in it
remember in JavaScript in an hour like
the ground Corbett you just need some
lightweight Dom wrappers you need
setters for the different types of
properties you want to set and yeah so
it could be possible and it would be
very cool yeah so to be honest I started
I started trying to make angular work
with this kind of benchmark but in the
end I I understood that it doesn't
really make sense
mostly because angular has like a crazy
complicated way of doing Dom
reconciliation by tracking changes and
stuff and that's totally fine but for me
it just seemed so backwards that I yeah
I couldn't really wrap my head around it
but as yeah again someone pointed me to
angular IV which is the next generation
rendering engine and they are using
something that I think looks kind of
similar to this for very performant
rendering yeah
so that's the exact thing you don't
detect it you don't care about whether
it has change the only detection you
need you didn't select something so
either you need to just rear-end her on
every frame just say now you just need
to get it in sync I was doing that for a
long time now I see that I it's probably
not necessary so now the default is that
we just rerender on every Dom event that
has been handled and when you use some
server-side thing to fetch data and
stuff like that you will in a few places
in your code need to call Impa commit
which is basically saying be where
something might have changed you should
just try to get it all in sync yeah cool
so again if you have other questions or
want to check out scream bar and get
speak me and my co-founder are here
having a huge stand with tons of stuff
no pinball game yeah yeah that's a good
question so I think please this to first
to maybe 20 let me see if that if you
reset this now there are 20 items here
reset this run the benchmark my guess is
I don't remember but my guess is it's
about the same the same different it
might even be a little faster but I
don't I'm not sure and my guess would be
that it is faster because it's basically
like the more stuff you're trying to
yeah it's actually faster yeah cool so
that's that's the talk I almost spent
the time thank you
you